bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct on passe tout de suite au
titre en images de cette édition plus de
trente ans après plaisir retrouve les
joutes de la fédérale 2 après sa
victoire ce dimanche face à chartres en
16e de finale retour récit complet à
suivre ils terminent leur préparation
pour leur traversée de l'océan pacifique
à la rame nous serons en duplex de san
francisco avec les deux idiots à clément
elio et christophe papillon à dix jours
du départ ce samedi la star française du
mma cheikh congo animer un stage au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une occasion
inespérée de prendre quelques conseils
pour les amateurs passionnés évidemment
en fin d'émission comme d'habitude tous
les résultats du week-end l'on passe
tout de suite à notre page spéciale foot
bull
vous avez peut-être déjà découvert cette
discipline sur internet ou dans certains
centres de foot en salle
je parle bien sûr du football oui oui
vous avez bien entendu le football et la
discipline à la mode en ce moment et les
fondateurs de la société sont sur le
plateau du 7-8 sport tout d'abord palata
azim beau et xavier à l'ag bonsoir à
tous et merci d'être là alors évidemment
la première question qui me brûle élèves
c'est qu'est ce que c'est le football
vous allez c'est un sport dans lequel
vous prenez enfin c'est un sport qui
ressemble un peu au football dans lequel
vous êtes protégé par une bulle en est
au complet à l'air et puis vous pouvez
prendre tous les tout un tas de de
contacts qui vous permettent de ne pas
avoir de douleur qui est vraiment sans
risque qui se peut qu'ils ce qui se
pratique sur quel type de terrain qui
sera terrain de 90 mètres qu'on peut
vouloir sur l'intérieur autant sa longue
pratique sur tous les terrains ce dans
les gymnases avec les collectivités ou
dans les centres de foot indoor avec
tout type d'âge donc on démarre à 8 ans
ont tous démarré avec des enfants l'âge
de 8 ans et après y'a pas d'âge limite
est alors pas la tâche mais je me tourne
vers vous les règles est ce qu'elles
sont identiques au football traditionnel
au football dit classique on à dire vous
pas où ça change un petit peu
en fait c'est le même principe le but
c'est de marquer un but un but de plus
que l'adversaire
sachant que le tac est l'adversaire peut
lui rentrer dedans avec l'abus c'est
l'attrait principal on va dire
d'ailleurs je crois que vous êtes venu
avec il fallut un exemplaire de bulle ça
c'est pour les les enfants vous m'avez
dit c'est ça tu t'en vas partir de 8 ans
a mené le voit la liaison qui est
imposant évidemment donc ça c'est pour
laisser le modèle enfant alors donc le
football l'accessoire indispensable
c'est la bulle
évidemment ça a un goût j'imagine
comment ça fonctionne pour est-ce qu'on
peut s'en acheter ou c'est vraiment vous
qui a amené tout clé en main et puis les
joueurs viennent profiter de l'esma nous
on propose un service clé en main c'est
à dire que
les gens nous propose un terrain sur
lequel ils veulent pratiquer non se
déplace avec notre matériel ont fait une
animation donc avec les enfants les
adultes on propose différents jeux pour
les enterrements de vie de garçons pour
les enterrements de vie de jeune fille
ou même les collectivités avec les
enfants les primaires les ados il ya
vraiment tout un public qui est vraiment
vraiment derrière ce genre d'activité et
qui peut rassembler même des pratiques
mix même avec les femmes les hommes
peuvent jouer ensemble et généralement
c'est vraiment très fun on le voyait sur
les images vous parliez de contact il
n'y a pas de risque de blessure parce
qu'on voit quand même de sacrés chacun
dans le football
non en fait c'est là c'est la ville qui
absorbe les chocs du coup en attendant
la bulle elle est protégée par apporte
tous les tous les contacts qu'on risque
là il n'y a pas de risque de tourner et
de nausées parce que je vois qu'on peut
faire des sauts périlleux un peu à
volontaire parce que c'est un peu à
cause de l'inertie est en fait la bulle
vous protège au niveau de la tête
vraiment largement au dessus de la tête
donc ce qui fait que si vous tournez si
vous tombez est allé août
elle est en dessous des fesses donc même
au niveau du même au niveau des jambes
il ya aucun risque en fait vous tombez
sur la bulle vous rebondissez comme si
vous tombiez sur un coussin d'air comme
si vous souhaitiez sur votre propre
matelas en fait donc au final vous
pouvez rentrer dans quelqu'un d'autre
votre tête touchera pas votre corps
touchera pas et donc même si vous prenez
une paroi où le sol il y aura vraiment
aucun risque là dessus et les taxes sont
ils autorisés à l'intérieur de la bulle
ou pas ça laissait bien sûr
difficilement réalisable donc est ce que
il faut être bon joueur de football pour
être bon en football où où c'est
complètement indépendant s'est avéré but
c'est du fait du faible au fait pour
penser football est pas allé par
football parce que généralement il ya
déjà des imprimés des footeux qui
prennent à bail que c'est de faire des
passements de jambes sauf que là il ya
l'adversaire qu'il rentre dedans qui
récupère la balle donc du coup c'est la
stratégie totalement différente c'est ça
et alors du coup comment on devient bon
au football alors il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de manière de devenir bon si
vous laissez c'est déjà prendre s'amuser
c'est prendre du plaisir à faire une
pratique sportive faire une activité
donc je vous dis qui est destiné à tout
le monde est vraiment ce pouvoir se rend
sur l'entraînement et il n'y a pas de
celle foot champagne si c'est ça le
fighting spirit britannique qui avait
justement parlant de britanniques où il
ya des lits qui commence à se développer
en france on commence aussi à développer
vraiment on est surtout le secteur ile
de france se développe sur toute la
france actuellement
on a des appels un peu partout donc nous
pour cet été avec les collectivités
locales puisque on se déplace dans leur
gymnase ce genre de choses il ya
vraiment la dispo la possibilité de
faire ça avec tout le monde
que vous soyez sportif pas sportif ça
s'adresse à tout le monde en fait on a
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas forcément
footballeurs qui sont même pas forcément
sportifs qui viennent et qui pratique ça
puisqu'on peut le faire avec tout le
côté sportif certes il ya aussi le côté
fun éducatif avec les jeunes justement
parce qu'il ya ce côté où on peut se
rentrer dedans et on peut perdre cette
appréhension du contact donc mam avec
des personnes qui ont des handicaps qui
ont dit qu'il peut avoir des handicaps
on peut le pratiquer vraiment avec tout
le monde d'accord c'est très très
intéressant et du coup est ce que cette
nouvelle pratique on va dire se fait
déjà en compétition il ya des
compétitions qui commence à naître de
football ou pas qui rend complice en
équipe afin de mettre en place l'équipe
de france de foot bull pouvoir
concurrencer les anglais vous parliez
justement d un instant des personnes qui
sont pas pratiquantes le football on
peut le conseiller à une personne qui
voudrait se remettre au sport faire un
peu de cardio par exemple faire du
cardio oui on peut après tout dépend de
la blessure qui a été quand même fait
avant si vous n'allez pas conseillé à
quelqu'un qui s'est fait d une rupture
des croisés d'aller tout de faire un
match de foot ou d'aller faire un match
de basket donc là c'est exactement
pareil peu importe la blessure que vous
avez eue avant il ya toujours de toute
façon à un délai avec avant de faire
après ça s'applique à tout le monde
c'est à dire que vous ayez été blessé
que vous soyez sportif pas sportif ça
s'applique vraiment à tous
on a des enfants vraiment très jeune qui
le font on a des gens qui sont pas
sportifs de qui ont plus de 40 ans
qu'ils le font aussi
il ya aucun risque et c'est ça qui est
vraiment bien par contre c'est vrai que
c'est très agréable de pouvoir se
rentrer dedans tout en famille tout en
ami avec des collègues avec les copains
de classe ou ce genre de choses c'est
sûr c'est toujours amusant très bien ont
du coup si vous aussi vous voulez
découvrir le football on peut vous
retrouvez sur votre site internet
www.footbel.com et puis évidemment
essayer ce sport qui a fait un tabac
dans notre rédaction merci beaucoup à
tous les deux repasser sur le 7-8 sport
et puis à très bientôt peut-être pour un
j'ai testé pour vous en rugby j'en
parlais dans les titres après son
seizième finale retour victorieux face à
chartres le prc validé son ticket pour
la fédérale 2 est évidemment après plus
de 30 ans d'attentes tout le peuple
jaune et bleu
attendez ça dans un robert barro plein à
craquer bouillon comme à ses plus
grandes heures ces chartes qui prend le
meilleur envol
les visiteurs mènent rapidement 8 à 3
après un essai une pénalité qui seront
d'ailleurs leur seul point du match
paralysés par l'enjeu de la fédérale 2
les joueurs du prc se retrouve comme
souvent dans la combativité et la
solidarité
les bleu et jaune garde la tête hors de
l'eau et rentre aux vestiaires avec deux
points de retard sharks mènent 8 à 6 je
pense qu'on avait dû le jouer 10 fois
dans la nuit le match et les joueurs en
gros raté tout ce qu'ils ont entrepris
quoi donc de l'extérieur ça devait être
pas très beau à voir
heureusement qu'on a gardé l'état
d'esprit de solidarité défensive et
d'agressivité qui nous a permis quand
même pas de tenir le choc en prend à mi
temps quand ils ont bien joué
laurie plaisir wav a sonné peu avant
l'heure de jeu le pack du prc se
transforme alors en entreprise de
démolition des mailles du rideau
défensif blanc et sur ce lancer en
touche tout un peuple va aplatir le
ballon
un père semaine alors 11 à 8 mais doit
encore résister vingt longues minutes à
chaque possession des joueurs
d'eure-et-loir la tension grimpe d'un
cran mais plaisir tient bon daisy vinoy
s'impose finalement 11,8 se qualifie
pour les huitièmes de finale et surtout
s'ouvrent les portes de la fédérale 2
plus de trente ans que le club attendait
ça c'est un groupe construit depuis dix
ans et on a travaillé dur cette année
pour ça pour arriver là et quelle que
soit la manière on a réussi à le faire
et c'est ce le fruit disant trahi je
suis très fier et je vous le rappelle je
vous le disais dans les titres de ce
sept huit sports on va essayer d'avoir
notre équipage yvelinois qui se prépare
à la great pacific chris cléments helio
et christophe papillon qui sont à
l'heure actuelle à san francisco on
essaye d'établir la liaison
ce samedi la star française du mma
cheikh congo animer un stage au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une occasion
inespérée de prendre quelques conseils
auprès de la star pour les amateurs
passionnés julien leroy pour les images
sur un tatami posé sur l'air central de
la piste du vélodrome
cheick kongo revient sur les bases de la
lutte avec sa cinquantaine de stagiaires
au programme de la matinée de la garde
et de la lutte gréco romaine
par contre comme si c'est une partie
d'échecs fait de pouvoir justement
mettre en place la protège y adéquat
chante pouvoir mettre à mal l'adversaire
donc aussi bien pour pouvoir le placer
le coup qui le mettra
entre guillemets chaos ou sinon la
soumission qui lui permettra de
d'abonnés de combat centre beaubourg la
discipline dans laquelle cheikh congo
excellent le mma est un mélange de boxe
pieds poings et de lutte au quotidien le
champion vit et s'entraîne en californie
aux etats unis
profitez de ces précieux conseils lors
de ce stage est presque inespéré c'est
impressionnant et puis on sait enfin le
palmarès la carrière sportif sportive
pardon qui là bas c'est vrai que c'est
sympa puisque d'habitude on le voyait
plus à la télé lors de ces combats aux
états unis donc donc là le pouvoir le
voir en vrai alors d'explication tester
des dessous des des choses avec lui
c'est c'est vraiment cool c'est très
positive nous si les maj 8 encore
parfois d'une réputation sulfureuse
cheikh congo tient à cadrer ses élèves
sur les principes de sa discipline
surtout justement éviter toutes les
petites dérives qu'il y a
dans le sport comme certains peuvent
penser que c'est un sport brutal et
sanguinaire que l'on nous sommes que
nous sommes dénué de sentiments et on
pense qu'à la violence non facéties du
partage s'il a échoué au titre mondial
au bellator il ya un mois à tout juste
trente neuf ans le champion espère
monter dans la cage et sur les rings
pendant encore deux années
il ya tout juste quelques semaines cet
ovaire à maurepas le premier centre de
test de vélo en france un concept
novateur qui permettent aux passionnés
de pratiquer le vélo autrement images de
jonathan lynn passer par toutes les
disciplines du vélo et du vtt
florian l'écuyer a pu appréhender le
deux roues sur tous les terrains alors
quand l'entreprise qui l'emploie ferme
il ya un an et demi il ne veut pas
quitter les braquer et crée bike and
test l'utilité de cette jeune société
permettre l'essai de modèles vendus
uniquement sur internet
beaucoup de marques fondation internet
toutes ces marques n'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir un peu juste et
regarder sur internet regarder des
essais magazine des essais voilà deux
sites internet
mais concrètement on peut pas avoir le
produit on peut pas laisser m voilà il
ya un réel manque la danse pour ça que
cet espace est désormais le premier
centre de tests en france entièrement
dédié au vélo un essai en fonction du
modèle et de la durée coûte entre 25 et
60 10 euros
et en cas d'achat le client est
automatiquement remboursés avec près de
700 kilomètres carrés de bois et de
forêts dans le département par la suite
florian l'écuyer aimerait permettre aux
vététistes de rouler sur des circuits
officiels
ce que je voudrais faire c'est
développer des sentiers balisés
fédération française de cyclisme
parce que c'est un gros problème dans la
région c'est qu'on a de plus en plus de
réglementation pour aller dans les
forêts je pense que ce serait un bon
point pour la région d'avoir des
circuits justement balisé spécialement
pour les vététistes avec l'implantation
du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou encore des
courses comme la revancharde
nul doute que cette entreprise est parti
pour rouler sur tous les terrains
allez on passe à l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end
une fois n'est pas coutume on commence
par du football et ce week-end se jouer
la 21e et avant dernière journée de
promotion d'honneur et citrap a enfin
retrouvé la victoire 4 à 3 face à
paris-xiii guyancourt a grillé un joker
en vue du maintien vous le voyez le sg
s'est incliné sur la pelouse de logis à
maccabi paris concurrent direct pour la
survie un but à 0 et au classement cette
défaite complique sérieusement les
affaires de guyancourt les joueurs de
jupes talmont rose reste 11e de cette
poule c avec 40 points est toujours
relégable lors de la dernière journée ce
dimanche le sg devra obligatoirement
s'imposer en espérant un faux-pas du
pecq 10e pour se maintenir
chez les femmes et l'encours infligé une
correction à paris-xiii toujours en
promotion d'honneur 5 but à 0 grâce à
cette sixième victoire de la saison les
amazones gagnent une place au classement
et sont désormais sixièmes en tennis 4e
journée du championnat de france par
équipe en nationale une baie plaisir n'a
fait qu'une bouchée du tennis club de
paris victoire nette et sans bavure 6
matchs à zéro plaisir et vite
évidemment pardon toujours leader de sa
poule en nationale 3 l'équipe réserve
plaisir was a concédé le nul à domicile
face au stade français 3 matches partout
et reste lanterne rouge de sa poule
chez les femmes sévère défaite en
revanche des plaisirs waes sur les
courts de trembler 6 matchs à zéro elles
sont quatrièmes de leur poule au
classement général il y avait du
baseball ce week-end et la 6e journée de
division 2 on suit évidemment montigny
vous le savez deuxième recevait le
cinquième reine après un match aller qui
avait vu la victoire des bretons dont il
n'y a pu prendre sa revanche
les joueurs d'alexandre coton se sont
baladés 1 ce dimanche il faut le dire
sur leur terrain domicile succès ce
succès s est à deux le matin et 14 à 4
l'après-midi la phase de repérage et de
rodage des premières journées semblent
bien loin avec l arrivée du nouvel
entraîneur alexandre couton montigny est
tourné vers les playoffs c'est un petit
peu dur c'est vrai au départ on s'était
quand même on avait c'est de bien se
préparer mais
mais on a eu pas mal d'absents la
première journée maintenant ça va mieux
on a trouvé notre rythme on n'est pas
encore à 100% mais je pense que la
deuxième partie de championnat va être
meilleure que la première
cette semaine se tenait la 22e édition
du tiebreak ce tournoi de golf caritatif
à la queue-lez-yvelines compétition
organisée au profit de l'association sos
gazelles à laquelle participaient de
nombreux anciens sportifs comme tatiana
golovin ou encore patrice alger lower
qui est désormais entraîneur de tennis
si la compétition est plutôt symbolique
il faut le dire ces anciens athlètes
conserve tout de même l'envié de gagner
et mais cette fois ci dans la bonne
humeur à fond il avait vu là comme on a
attaqué le green sérieux oui c'est à
fond d'accord t'as jamais vu ce niveau
de professionnalisme
avez vous nous dire aussi qu'on a réussi
à tuer de bichat quand même donc le
dîner de ce soir est assurée donc et
pour la petite histoire c'est cédric
pioline l'ancien tennisman qui a
remporté le trophée des champions du 22e
tiebreak ce samedi le stade mont boron
de versailles accueillait la cinquième
édition des olympiades du vivre ensemble
où près de 1000 personnes ont pu
découvrir de nombreuses disciplines
comme l' escalade ou encore le chant de
barra et avoir un autre regard sur le
handicap les personnes handicapées ont
également pu nouer des relations avec de
futurs clubs qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à pouvoir accueillir les
athlètes handisport un parcours qu'a
connu il ya presque huit ans le
tennisman yoann qui ou laurent bolitar
découvert le tennis fauteuil à l'âge de
21 ans
par un concours de circonstances je peux
vous dire que ça a été vraiment si
facile que ça de trouver puisque des
sections n'y en a pas tant que ça
surtout dans les yvelines un peu plus
mais moi je suis issu d'eure-et-loir et
y en avait pas du tout en eure-et-loir
et en fait c'est pure par hasard par
contact sur internet j'ai tapé on va
dire des sports sur la ville la plus la
ville à côté de chez moi et du coup j'ai
trop le contact qui m'a permis de
rentrer au niveau de la section 10 sport
et tester le tennis fauteuil puisque
c'est mon sport et il faut croire que le
hasard a bien fait les choses puisque
johan guillou en 2014 à ce lundi pointe
d
on remet au 26e rang mondial de tennis
fauteuil
encore une info avant de passer à votre
agenda du week-end vous le savez les
féminines de l'entente que le chesnay
versailles en basket on fait l'ascenseur
cette saison et l'entraîneur stéphane
drolet devrait quitter ses fonctions
et selon nos informations son successeur
serait en réalité son ex prédécesseur il
s'agit de vinko bar dietsch l'homme qui
a permis à le lcv de remonter en l1
cette saison on passe désormais à votre
agenda du week-end et de rendez vous à
ne pas rater ce week-end tout d'abord là
le retour de la grande classique
bordeaux paris 26 ans après la dernière
édition le la caci fait donc ce wiki
seront son retour ce week-end avec des
coureurs qui parcourront plus de 600 km
sur trois jours vendredi samedi et
dimanche et surtout dimanche l'arrivée
qui compte pour nous ce dimanche au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il y aura du football 22e et dernière
journée de promotion d'honneur pour
guyancourt qui reçoit fleury mérogis au
stade maurice baquet coup d'envoi à
15h30
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain d'ici là je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur téléfilm